today's video is brought to you by monk
pack tasty low sugar keto friendly snack
bars more on them in just a bit
once upon a time during the closing days
of the wild west there was a group of
mean and dangerous brothers called the
daltons and together with their friends
they formed a gang that liked to rob
banks and trains steal horses and any
other illicit activity that might make
them some money anyone who tried to
interfere with their felonious
enterprises at a good chance of getting
pumped full of lead and ditched by the
side of the road but then october 5th
1892 gang leader bob dalton decided that
five of them would enter the city of
coffeyville kansas and robbed two banks
at once in broad daylight to show the
whole world that the dalton gang was the
most feared group of outlaws in the wild
west but things didn't really go his way
and a massive shootout ensued between
the dalton gang and the people of
coffeeville when the smoke settled eight
people were dead including four of the
five gang members bob dalton was dead as
was his brother grant bill powers and
dick broadwell youngest brother emmett
dalton was the only survivor despite
sustaining dozens of wounds even so he
was arrested and sentenced to life in
prison and just like that the dalton
gang was no more except that a fourth
brother named bill dalton was still
around on that fateful day he and
another outlaw named bill doolin may
have been waiting outside the city with
fresh horses to help the gang make their
escape once they found out what had
happened to the others they resolved to
form a new group led by the two of them
often they say that the sequel is never
as good as the original but that was not
the case here as the dulin dalton gang
became more successful more notorious
and longer lived than the first
incarnation eventually it gained a new
name to match its fearsome reputation it
became known as the wild bunch
[Music]
mason dalton was born circa 1865 in cass
county missouri to lewis dalton and
adeline younger the family relocated to
kansas where mason and his 14 siblings
grew up later in life he started going
by william bill dalton so we're just
going to call him that from the
beginning to make it a whole lot less
confusing there are already enough
daltons going around in this video to
use one with two names his mother was
related to the younger brothers who were
part of the notorious james younger gang
alongside frank jesse james the gang
predated the wild bunch by a couple of
decades so bill dalton and his brothers
grew up hearing of their uncle's daring
and violent exploits even so for a while
it seemed like the dalton boys were
destined to walk on the right side of
the law the family's pride and joy was
frank dalton in 1884 he became a deputy
u.s marshal for the oklahoma territory
and was considered by his peers to be a
brave and respected lawman however he
was gunned down in 1887 while attempting
to arrest a horse thief at first the
other dalton brothers thought they could
pick up the mantle left behind by big
brother frank grat dalton took over his
job as deputy marshall and then hired
bob and emmett to serve as guards but it
became pretty obvious soon enough that
they weren't meant to walk the straight
and narrow it started with too much
drinking and too much gambling on the
job then there were the incidents when
the brothers got a bit too trigger-happy
and it ended with plain old corruption
as the boys sought to supplement their
meager salaries by abusing their
authority sometimes they would find a
person instead of arresting them other
times they would confiscate legal goods
but every time the cash and cargo seemed
to mysteriously vanish before reaching
the sheriff's station ultimately the
brothers said screw it and they started
their gang as far as bill dalton was
concerned he too tried to live an honest
life at first he started out working
various odd jobs with his brothers
before moving to livingston california
where he was employed by a rancher named
cyrus bliven soon after bill fell in
love with the ranch's daughter jenny
bliven the two got married in 1885 and
had two children together charles and
grace it really seemed like bill dalton
had his life together he started a
family he bought his own ranch he opened
a business and even got involved in
local politics the people who knew him
described him as charming good looking
at the life of the party so what exactly
possessed him to turn to a life of crime
it seems that his brothers had a
negative influence on bill bob and grat
and emmett sometimes showed up bill's
ranch for a visit when they were looking
to lay low from the authorities it is
possible that the brothers committed
several robberies in the late 1880s and
early 1890s and used bill's ranch as a
hideout but it is uncertain if bill ever
joined them in any of their ventures he
finally showed up on the sheriff's radar
in 1891 when somebody committed a train
robbery in the town of alilah california
which involved the murder of a
locomotive fireman named george
radcliffe bob and emmitt dalton were
wanted for the crime he managed to flee
to california but bill and gret dalton
were arrested for helping them escape
even though all charges against bill
were eventually dropped his reputation
was tarnished forever and he was
considered to be just another no good
dalton boy at this point there was no
use in pretending anymore so bill
accepted his new role in life as an
outlaw although we're not really sure to
what extent he participated in the
illicit activities of the dalton gang
who knows after the coffeeville massacre
with his brothers dead or in jail bill
may have been tempted to return to
ranching if it wasn't for another man
[Music]
we're on with the second namesake of the
doolin dalton gang william doolan born
circa 1858 on a homestead northeast of
clarksville arkansas his parents were
michael doolin and artemia bella a pair
of law-abiding sharecroppers bill worked
on the family farm until 1881 at which
point the 23 year old left the homestead
to find his own way in life like bill
dalton he didn't seem to be particularly
inclined toward a life of crime which
makes it all the more curious that they
ended up leading one of the most
notorious gangs of the wild west in the
oklahoma territory doolin found work as
a cowboy on the ranch of a texan named
oscar halsell who liked bill enough to
take him under his wing and teach him to
read and write this was doolan's life
for the next 10 years drifting from one
ranch to another filling whatever
position was needed we know that during
this time he met some of the men who
would later form part of his gang but
we're not sure exactly what prompted
bill to turn to robbery by 1891 however
he was a member of the dalton gang and
became an outlaw following a shootout in
coffeeville kansas strangely enough this
isn't the aforementioned bloody gunfight
that got the two dalton brothers killed
and ended the gang this happened a year
earlier when doolin and a few cohorts
wanted to celebrate the 4th of july with
a keg of beer but kansas was a dry state
at the time and the local lorman didn't
take kindly to drunkards around there
except that doolin and his friends
didn't take kindly to local lawmen
trying to confiscate their hooch so both
sides started shooting at each other
resulting in two injuries and a life on
the run for bill doolin tulin had a
somewhat contentious relationship with
the dalton brothers particularly bob
dalton who often acted as the leader of
the group some sources claim that doolin
briefly left the gang alongside two
other members named charlie pierce and
george bittercreek newcomb who are worth
mentioning as they would later be a part
of the wild bunch all three of them were
angry with the daltons because they felt
bob wasn't quite equitable when it came
to divvying up the loot it seems this
was one of those situations where
everyone was equal but some were more
equal than the others and some of the
core members of the dalton gang received
bigger shares than the rest ultimately
this worked out in doolin's favor after
all if he were one of bob dalton's
trusty sidekicks then he probably would
have been present in coffee pill on the
day of the gunfight and ended up in a
cheap box right next to bob and the
others but as things stood after october
5th 1892 bill doolin was now an
independent gunman ready to strike out
on his own all right we'll get back to
our video in just a second but first
here's a word from today's fantastic
sponsor monk pack bunk pack offers low
sugar keto friendly bars which are
plant-based gluten-free and non-gmo but
the perfect snack for anyone who's
trying to eat better or cut back on
sugar and carbs without sacrificing
taste monk back keto granola bars and
nuts and seed bars this is nuts and
seeds this is one of their granola bars
they contain one gram of sugar or less
two to three grams of net carbs and each
bar contains 150 calories or less look
everyone snacks for me when i get home
from work there's probably some crisps
in the cupboard that my wife has bought
and i'll be like yeah let's stack up
those because they're tasty but since
having monk pack in my cupboard i just
grab one of these and it is tasty it is
delicious this is probably my favorite
the caramel sea salt flavor i just uh
like the salty and sugary goodness i
just love that and i just see one of
these instead it satiates that after
work hunger and i don't end up eating
crisps which i know are horribly bad for
me mark back have a great chewy texture
and they come in delicious favors like
sea salt dark chocolate the one i
mentioned coconut cocoa chip and caramel
sea salt they're perfect for a quick
breakfast a snack between zoom calls or
as a guilt-free decadent dessert
tasty stuff you guys get 20 off
finish my mouthful
20 of your first purchase
of any month pack product by visiting
monkback.com and entering my code
biography so checkout and monk pack is
so confident in their products is back
with 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
exchange the product or refund your
money whichever you prefer and now back
to today's video
[Music]
after the bloody shootout at coffeeville
doolan newcomb and pierce felt obligated
to visit the dalton household and pay
their respects the family matriarch who
had just buried two sons and saw another
imprisoned for life while there they met
up with bill dalton and doolin floated
the idea of the four of them starting a
new gang and picking up right where
things left off bill accepted and the
doolen dalton gang was born truth be
told bill dulan was the de facto leader
of the group bill dalton didn't really
have the credentials to lead gang but
they probably added him in honor of his
brothers and for brand recognition since
the dalton name was already known and
feared throughout the west of course
four men might make a nice barb shop
quartet but they are not enough for a
dangerous gang so the first thing they
did was to draft a few more names to
their roster we're not going to go
through all of them just know that 11
men were part of the wild bunch at one
point or another they all had colorful
names like william tulsa jack blake and
dan dynamite dick clifton and they all
ultimately met their ends in violent
shootouts so
well expect a lot of gunfights in the
very near future in fact let's start
right now we believe that the first
crime committed by the new and improved
gang was the robbery of the ford county
bank in spearville kansas on november 1
1892. following their escape the
authorities identified one of the gunmen
as oliver olyantis and put the marshals
on his trail they tracked down yantas at
his sister's ranch on the 29th of
november and gunned him down when the
outlaw refused to surrender gantus died
of his wounds the next day becoming the
first member of the wild bunch to go out
in a hail of bullets just a month after
the gang was formed the rest of the
outlaws were more successful and spent
the first half of 1893 robbing multiple
trains and banks without too much hassle
but on september 1st they took part in
one event remembered in western law as
one of its fiercest gunfights and
solidified their reputation as the wild
bunch it became known as the battle of
ingles named after the town of ingles
oklahoma which the criminals sometimes
used as a hideout as we mentioned by
that point the gang had plenty of
successful robberies under its belt so
it was firmly on the radar of the u.s
marshals who vowed to risk life and limb
in order to bring the wild bunch to
justice on september 1st 1893 a posse of
over a dozen marshals led by john nixon
tracked the outlaws to ingalls most of
the gang members had been there for
weeks drinking gambling and most
importantly spending money which is why
the locals looked the other way when it
came to how they obtained their
forgotten gains as the marshals rode
into town all the criminals were playing
cards in the saloon except for roy dowdy
aka arkansas tom jones who was sick in
bed in his room of the ok hotel as
george newcomb exited the saloon the
marshals opened fire prompting all of
the outlaws to abandon their poker game
and responding kind within seconds the
tiny town of ingles transformed into a
war zone covered in smoke with bullets
flying in every direction hearing the
commotion outside arkansas tom jones
went to the window of his hotel room and
opened fire on the lawmen mortally
wounding deputy marshal tom houston the
surprise attack allowed some of the
other outlaws to make their way to the
stable and retrieve their horses they
charged out of delivery with their guns
blazing and killed two more marshals
lafayette shadley and dick speed as well
as an innocent bystander who got caught
in the crossfire with the lawmen on the
defensive the wild bunch was able to
ride out of town with only a few minor
injuries to show for their troubles
there was still a little matter of
arkansas tom jones who was trapped
inside his hotel room given that they
had just lost three of their own the
marshals were in no mood to negotiate so
they gave jones two options surrender or
they'd throw dynamite in his room jones
surrendered was arrested and later
convicted to 50 years in prison although
he was released after serving less than
20. strangely enough getting caught
prolonged his life substantially as he
outlived all of his compatriots by two
to three decades however during the
1920s jones started robbing banks again
and in 1924 he was finally killed in a
gunfight in joplin missouri as the last
of the wild bunch
[Music]
after making an escape from ingles the
rest of the gang decided to lay low for
the rest of the year but in 1894 they
were back to their old shenanigans and
by shenanigans we of course mean robbery
violence and the occasional murder a
stagecoach in arkansas a train in
oklahoma bank in kansas little by little
the wild bunch were becoming the biggest
terror in the west but it was their
little stunt in engles that made them
public enemies number one in the eyes of
the marshals undoubtedly there were more
than a few lawmen who would have loved
to catch the gang members in their
crosshairs the officers doggedly pursued
the wild bunch from state to state led
by a famed tree of marshals named bill
tillman heck thomas and chris madsen who
were collectively known as three
guardsmen and who knows maybe one day
we'll cover them on biographics as well
anyway having the law constantly on
their trail didn't seem to deter the
wild bunches the gang committed one
brazen act after another including a
daring raid on southwest city missouri
which saw the wild bunch successfully
ride out of town following a bank
robbery despite the fact that marshalls
and townspeople fired at them from both
sides of the street as the gang was
making its getaway there was another
successful score that left the gang
unscathed and almost four thousand
dollars richer it really seemed like the
wild bunch had more than a few rabbits
feed tucked away somewhere in their
saddles the way they kept avoiding any
serious injuries but their luck was
about to run out and it started with
none other than bill dalton on june 8
1894 dalton was lying low at his home in
ardmore oklahoma when a posse of armed
lorman surrounded the house if bill
would have exited his home hands held
high in the air he might have survived
but that's not how things played out
instead he jumped out the window gun in
hand and started running towards the
posse it was one final act of defiance
from a man who decided to go out on his
own terms as you might imagine he was
immediately ripped to shreds by the hell
of gunfire the final dalton had been
dealt with marking an end to one of the
most feared names to come out of the old
west his wife who stuck by his side and
raised the kids while he was out with
the rest of the wild bunch identified
his body and had it shipped to
california to be buried for the rest of
the gang even with dalton's death it was
business as usual since it was unlikely
that any of them expected to make it to
old age anyway even so the rest of the
year was pretty quiet with no other
notable events occurring in 1894. 1895
however was a completely different story
as all the other wild bunch members
started getting picked off one by one
first off tulsa jack blake on april 3
1895 five members of the gang had just
robbed another train near rock island
oklahoma and made camp for the night in
a basin along the simmering river
unbeknownst to him a posse of us
marshall sniffed out their train and
approached their camp in the dead of
night the lawmen called for the outlaws
to surrender but of course this was
never going to happen another wild
shootout erupted and roughly 200 shots
later the gunsmoke cleared blake lay
dead while the rest of the bandits
managed to make their escape just a
month later the wild bunch lost two of
its founding members george bittercreek
newcomb and charlie pierce on may the
second the two of them traveled to the
dunn ranch in payne county oklahoma
nukem wanted to visit his lover a woman
named rose dunn pretty famous in her own
right but better known as rose of
cimarron the gang were also on friendly
terms with their brothers who they knew
from engle so newcomen peers felt pretty
safe as they approached the ranch what
they didn't know is that the dunn
brothers preferred money over friendship
and they intended to collect on the
large bounties placed on all members of
the wild bunch so then newcomb and
pierce showing up at their home was like
a turkey basting and stuffing itself and
then jumping into the oven on its own
volition the temptation was just too
great so as the two unsuspecting outlaws
got off their horses they were ambushed
and gunned down and the dunn brothers
became several thousand dollars richer
four months later another member of the
gang named little bill raidler was shot
and injured by one of the three
guardsmen and taken in alive he was sent
to jail for 10 years but released in
1903 due to health issues and he died a
year later therefore bradley became the
only member of the wild bunch not to be
killed directly in a gunfight even
though his death came as a result of the
injuries that he sustained in his
shootout with the marshals by 1896 half
of the gang was gone and the other half
had split up hoping to evade the
authorities as long as possible george
redbuck weightman was killed in another
gunfight with the marshals on march the
4th 1896 while dynamite dick clifton and
little dick west were gunned down in
1897 and 1898 respectively we're left
with just one man bill doolin the leader
of the wild bunch in june 1896 guardsman
bill tillman captured him without
incident at eureka springs arkansas and
sent him to federal prison in guthrie
oklahoma to await trial as it happened
clifton was also in prison there so the
two of them and a dozen other inmates
executed a prison break on july the 5th
doolin ran away to his father-in-law's
farm in lawson oklahoma to be with his
wife and son perhaps he realized that it
was the end of the road for him so he
wanted one more chance to see his family
unsurprisingly marshall soon tracked him
down to the homestead on august 25 1896
they trapped doolin in an ambush like
dalton he could have surrendered but he
preferred to go out shooting so doolin
raised his gun and aimed it at the
marshals but didn't get a chance to pull
the trigger before one of the deputies
emptied a double-barreled shotgun
straight into his chest and then there
were none eleven violent deaths for
eleven violent men meant the end of the
most ruthless gang that the old west had
ever seen the gang known
as the wild bunch i hope you found
today's video interesting if you did
please do hit that like button below
don't forget to subscribe and thank you
for watching
[Music]